you can't always get what you want
spielen sie beim nominierungsparteitag
der republikaner im sommer 2016
dabei hat donald trump in dem moment
alles erreicht und genießt es sichtlich
stiller dagegen wird mike pence den er
für das amt des vize präsidenten
nominiert hat farblos schüchtern fast
schon verloren
dabei ist seine feste größe auf der
politischen bühne
lange jahre hat der jurist im
repräsentantenhaus seinen heimatstaat
indiana vertreten seit 2013 ist der
gouverneur des staates
ich bin traurig dass er als gouverneur
aufhört hat einen guten job gemacht aber
er wird ein exzellenter vize hoffentlich
auch mal präsident ich liebe trumps
enthusiasmus aber manchmal weißt du da
ist der trump und mike pence ist
beständig und ruhig und cool unter druck
und das ist sehr gut für das gesamtpaket
mike pence das tief verwurzelte
mittleren westen hier hat er studiert
geheiratet eine familie gegründet und
sich den evangelikalen angeschlossen
christ konservativ republikaner in
dieser reihenfolge
so hat er sich selbst einmal beschrieben
die bibel lehrt dass gott mann und frau
nach seinem antlitz erschaffen hat und
daran glaube ich herr vorsitzender ich
glaube dass gott das universum
erschaffen hat die erde und alles darauf
inklusive des menschen und ich glaube
dass auch die wissenschaft eines tages
verstehen wird das einzig die schöpfungs
theorie eine halbwegs rationale
erklärung für das universum bietet
unbeirrbar ideologisch etwas das auch in
penns biografie begründet ist mike pence
war katholik und demokrat bevor er
born again christian und republikaner
wurde das heißt er ist ein seine
bekehrung geschichte und deshalb ist
sind diese positionen für die er steht
konservativen positionen in
gesellschaftlichen fragen in moralischen
fragen deswegen deswegen sind diese
positionen so werden die mit solcher
überzeugungen vorgetragen
schlanker staat niedrige steuern legaler
zugang zu waffen dafür steht pence und
er ist gegen abtreibung leugnet den
klimawandel ist gegen lgbt rechte als
gouverneur von indiana unterzeichnete
ein gesetz das mit religionsfreiheit
überschrieben ist und löst damit
empörung aus kein hass in unserem staat
rufen die demonstranten
denn die regelung hätte es
geschäftsleute auch ermöglicht
homosexuelle kundinnen abzuweisen fans
muss zurückrudern
ich glaube keinen augenblick dass es die
absicht unserer parlamentarier war
diskriminierung zu legitimieren
es geht auch nicht darum schwule und
lesben nicht zu bedienen und das war
auch nicht meine absicht
ich muss aber akzeptieren dass dieser
eindruck entstanden ist
in washington steht pence von anfang an
fest an der seite von donald trump in
die freiheits dessen bildungsministerin
durch einen part im senat blockiert wird
bringt pence sie mit seiner
entscheidenden stimme durch so etwas gab
es vorher noch nie außenpolitisch schick
trumps an vize oft vor
so muss der bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz den ausstieg seines
landes aus dem atom abkommen mit iran
erklären und für solidarität werben für
unsere europäischen partner ist die zeit
gekommen damit aufzuhören die
us-sanktionen gegen das mörderische
revolution regime zu untergraben
es ist zeit mit uns zusammen zu stehen
ist es zeit den atomdeal mit iran zu
kündigen
und dann trifft die korona pandemie die
usa so hart wie kein anderes land trat
er öffentlich die gefahr immer runter
spiel check pence vor
als leiter einer corona task force im
weißen haus
lange lässt trump ihn nicht gewähren
immer wieder übernimmt er die briefings
pence bleibt loyal und wird von trump im
sommer erneut für das amt des vize
präsidenten nominiert in diesen
herausfordernden zeiten braucht unser
land einen präsidenten der an amerika
glaubt er an die grenzenlosen
fähigkeiten des amerikanischen volkes
glaubt der sich herausforderungen stellt
jeden feind bekämpft und er die freiheit
verteidigt
amerika braucht präsident donald trump
für vier weitere jahre im weißen und
mike pence soll für entscheidende
stimmen bei der wahl sorgen
ähnlich wie in der kombination beiden
harris geht es auch für donald trump
herum mit part mit mike pence eine
entscheidende gruppe der
republikanischen wähler koalition
anzusprechen und zwar die weißen
evangelikalen und konservativen christen
und massig wissen viele evangelikale
christen dass das tram an dieser stelle
nicht einer der ihren ist mike pence ist
das insofern ergänzt er komplettiert er
dieses bild und gibt wie so eine art
schutzmantel für die offensichtliche
unmoral des präsidenten
trump pence und pence braucht trump
beide wollen eine weitere amtszeit im
weißen haus